so I thought I'd show you one of my
latest old computers later sold well you
get the idea quite a small one this time
it's just down there so you send me a
picture this and to me it looks just
like a tower computer but perhaps if you
stand next to it will get it senses the
actual scale of it I mean if I just sit
on it pretty large isn't that so tell us
about it what is it so this is actually
one of the nottingham computers from its
old servers it's been sitting in a
cupboard but it's a son three one six
three two the sun microsystems
workstation from the late 80s so it's a
deaf sized model and rather nicely if I
move the cables out the light it slides
in up against the desk at exactly the
right height so I believe one of the
other ones ended up its life as a coffee
table for Dave Brailsford we're going to
see if we can get it working there is a
slight issue with the amount of dust
inside if I switch it on you can hear
the noise it makes there's one red light
here I've got a serial link connecting
it to it and we can start to see the
self-test cover on the computer here
actually this computer from about 93 is
probably more powerful than that
although doesn't quite have as much
memory so it's testing the RAM at the
moment so at the moment I'm not going to
do much more than this so it's late 80s
if you look at the top you can see the
manufacturing thing says it was
assembled 2nd of June 1986 31 years old
come over to research 1st birthday so I
thought we'd get it out of retirement to
give it a new lease of life it sounds
like the fans are clogged with something
and it won't boot past the memory test
they will take it apart see what's
working and see how it's actually fitted
together
yeah why are you doing that man ask the
obvious questions a sticker on there
that says show like what's that all
about that was just the name of the
Machine the department at the time then
like to use names based off Robin Hood
so we had share if we had took we had
Robin and various other machines as that
machine called Marion as well the mail
server was called Pat and everyone in
the UK wonder why that is the case so
like that kind of slide inside out cars
yep so it was sort of Whaley's we shoot
these machines worked in those days
everything was on cards it's still the
case in fact if you go into a submarine
or something or any sort of an
environment like that you'll find very
similar sorts of cards being used it's
what's called the vmebus there's a
popular thing of motor oil at the time
but it enables you to sort of build the
system up you have a backplane at the
bat you see those connectors along here
and you just slide the cards into there
and then they can all talk over the
backplane to each other so you can
configure the Machine exactly you can
use on this one I've got the CPU card
here on the left
that's probably extra memory and we'll
have a look that one's just a blanking
plate this one's an additional Ethernet
card so it's got two Ethernet connectors
here and if you look back it from the
network diagram from the department at
the time you'll see it was used to link
two separate Ethernet together IC did
their works English it's not what I
normally do I'm normally more software
but I like playing with hard words so
hopefully we should be able to pull this
card out and without breaking anything
so he's just a blanking plate by the
look of it there's nothing on it this is
all them
sheet metal focus as heavy as well sheet
metal you can pull the cards out and
here we have what we go here I would say
this is RAM so you can see that there we
are another Robin Hood name much much
RAM - so there's eight Meg of RAM
I imagine this one actually produced by
some this board it's got a clear point
name on the top driver space of another
company figure you broaden your ramp and
it all connects back over the backplane
by these three connectors here and these
can carry the data signal and the
address signals and the control signals
from the CPU and the address and so you
can configure the machine as you liked
the difference now of course is you have
multiple layers this just seems to be a
two layer PCB I've already taken photos
of where all these boards went so you
can put it back together in the right
order we got this wire and again I think
this is just more RAM this is just
another this is actually for Meg
possibly to make eight Meg we along
those lines so you can see in there
we've now got the CPU card there which
has got its own memory on and various
other bits and pieces so we've got these
are that port on here some switches some
light video connect in order to put in a
display keyboard connector Mary I like
that that looks like an impressive bit
of engineering so there's the the back
of showing all the connections so what
we got on here for a special start is a
CPU this one's here it's a 68020
which is a Motorola CPU it's the same
family of CPUs that were found in the
Atari and the Amiga and it was good
because it's great for running UNIX
which is what this machine used at the
time so it's a six 8020 at the time the
amigas the Atari is the Macintosh is all
six eight thousand base machines this
one was later revision and so more
powerful we've also got a floating-point
code processor here and then this looks
like a boot ROM in some sorts that'll
have the BIOS equivalent or the boot
prom as it was called there and you've
got your network controller card there I
won't be too surprised if that's part of
the network as well and then you've got
lots and lots
discrete logic chips around here to do
things and the occasional programmable
logic array here this one's labeled how
at I don't think this is related but
powder and building similar form and
then here we've got ramps and the CPU
boards got memory on it I imagine
there's what 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 I'm
actually set up as parity RAM which is
what I've got more than 16 there and so
on and that will give you base amount of
memory I imagine about 4 megabytes
serial controller chip here same one is
used in the Macintosh and so this is
basically this is enough to start the
whole machine as the graphics cards on
here and well so you could build the
machine completely Alice and I think
some of the other Sun machines made use
of the same system how we're talking to
this what we got is a serial connection
which enables us to communicate to
another machine now normally in the
series either use the built-in graphics
or you've used double terminal I'm
actually connecting to a sort of Atari
here and they're just using on the
screen a simple terminal pro that snot
doing anything more than echoing what's
shown off this computer by the serial
link the most annoying thing about
trying to get this working so far is
that the connector use here is the
opposite to what's used on a PC or an
Atari so I've had to get a gender
changer to actually connect things
together that's been the most
complicated thing so far what happened
to some Sun so Sun they were started in
the early 80s they started producing
UNIX workstations based around six 8,000
for the Sun one was the first man this
was a bit later on they then develop
their own CPU the spark chip and
throughout the 90s if you wanted
powerful for the computers you would buy
some made a lot of things and then they
produced a little program you may have
heard of called Java which of course
became a reasonably popular operating at
an operating system really popular
virtual machine which could compile and
write programs towards and then sort of
about 2009-2010 they were bought out by
Oracle who basically bought them because
Solaris the operating system they
developed out of Unix to run these
things was probably the best one for
running the Oracle data
bass and so they still you can still get
the death descendants of this to run
Oracle databases but that's about it
Ethernet card coming out now so you can
start to see how it is sort of fitting
together I think what you've got at the
bottom and I'm sort of half guessing
here is that this will sort of decide
where in the computer's memory map the
network card will be addressed and so
sort of control logic on there for doing
various things you know some not gates
and and gates and so on in there and
then this bit here looks to be the
actual network card itself in fact you
can see if you look carefully from a
separate card I'm just using an Intel
LAN controller there looks like used to
make those out gold fantastically well
yes this is a ceramic chip package I
don't know quite where I got the gold
window on the top probably just keep the
light out but the interesting thing is
that it's got a a UI connector for
connecting up to the Ethernet it's not a
sort of BNC connector or rj45 that we're
used to these days you would have a big
cable that drop out the ceiling could
connect onto this and then inside the
ceiling you would have a huge thick
cable that you plug that onto in the
original instances one last card to come
out how much you think one of these
would have been back in the day
Oh several thousand it's not tens of
thousands so what we got here this is
another key card this is interesting
don't know what this one is it's got a
battery on it it's battery backed and
any clues it's what this one might be
the clock well it could be a clock of
some sort answers on a postcard - you
get a better view now of the backplane
there so these are all because at the
same if you look very carefully the left
there you'll see this a resistor pack
the red things so they'll be there to
terminate the buses just like you have
to terminate the network connection you
would have terminated to stop
reflections of the signals and make sure
things work as you'd expect and then
we've got two more boards here let's
have them out and have a look so this is
what we think my risk is e-card
xlc zero so that's probably it's
probably design logics car
little with another name all of the
machines we had that little job
absolutely getting the Robinhood naming
convention is another one so what we got
here is another biologics disk control
of some sort you've got a control crypt
in the middle and then the connectors
the different sort of connector
different size and then inside you can
just see the backplane there and the
clouds we just loved it's sliding and
connecting to that and everything then
connects ago if you look here you can
see this is very simple all the wires
just connect all the pins together into
these things and the capacitors just
provide a bit of smoothing on the power
supply Sun Microsystems model 160 a
backplane descriptive description anyway
get interesting it's a lot likes to move
now you can have a look at the hard
disks this one's got a tape drive fitted
here we've got a hard disk here it's a
lot of ribbon cable down here they want
to free and it seems at the front sort
of comes off so with a bit of brute
force and well intelligence but and get
the front off so we can start to see a
bit more disk drive configuration drive
nor drive one Fujitsu so it says
Micropolis inside so it may well have
been upgraded since then on/off switch
for the power fused by look of it in
fact here's the power supply here ETA
power systems and now we can see why is
it slightly out because of the cable
here it gave them to their so you can
see this is where scuzzy cable plugs in
here onto the back claim there can you
get that out this is what makes me a
computer file
success but fit but slow in that
connection part and I see can we add to
get the whole thing out Stanley did you
do anything countering that it's very
touch nuggets against a family I could
slide towards the front and that would
be good see a lot lots of dust in here
but we've got three things they've got
take Drive here which because you used
to load the media and things not sure
exactly the media left and we've got two
hard drives now which is sort of common
for the era these work very much like
old floppy driving you had two
connectors one that would control where
the heads were positioned over the
actual disc normal to read the data
across them and then you would have a
controller board inside your computer
what I think this machines got is you've
got to discussing controller boards here
and these allow you to talk to the
drives which we can actually down here
using scuzzy the small computer systems
interface and it's a way of connecting
hard drives I've got to stop me there
small computers you say well actually
bigger one as it not huge room side ones
but it's a small computer system
interface and the idea is it gives the
drive some intelligence so with these
sort of cards you have to physically
drive them by saying move this amount in
once you there read the data decode the
data and then you've got it with these
you can say get me this track and this
sector from this track on this cylinder
on this head and you're going to get it
and then send you the data and it allows
you to daisy-chain lots of things
together so if you look at the cable
it's got multiple connectors on it one
went into here and then the next one
hundreds of this one and so on this is a
scuzzy controller card which sort of
translates a scuzzy from the machine to
the actual hard disks so I think it's
going to go and blow the dust out of
this it might make sense but I'm getting
a rather nice shirt covered I am do my
bit for science and I should put my old
a-level lab coat on
[Music]
good
it's a dirty job but someone's got to do
it so just putting the CPU board and the
scuzzy board and we'll try booting up
jet we haven't broken anything but I
suspect they'll be some remedial work
before and get everything going again
that's quite easy the cards actually
sliding on rails which means we could
just line them up and just put
everything in it lined up and then
everything just slides into place so we
put the CPU card back in and the scuzzy
cards looking out to the disk and we're
tribe booting up and see what happens if
we get any different than what we had
before so that's a PI the serial cable
will start off and diagnostic mode
against we got that switched and we just
need some nice children thought evolve
hot power
let's try turning on it is doing its
self-test until you found four megabytes
now that's good for three energy we took
one of the cards out it should be faster
testing the RAM it's still just as noisy
self test path I've sent the boot off
the Suzy device device 1-0 see what
happened
nothing yet but there's seven possible
devices so hopefully we get device not
found it's not device one and you're
likely then they just happen it works
what would what would you set to see no
idea I've got this right yeah I might
see a device not not round
this is directly adding content to my
normal vision the problem is the area
that it has to add this content is
really very narrow I think it's the
equivalent of